-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy Award-winning actor,
you know from films such as,
"Field of Dreams,"
"Goodfellas,"
and "No Sudden Move."
He stars in the highly
anticipated "Sopranos" prequel,
"The Many Saints of Newark,"
which will be released
simultaneously in theaters and
on HBO MAX on October 1st.
Let's take a look.
-I'll tell you, Dick,
it's paradise over there.
On the one hand,
you can't believe the beauty.
On the other hand,
they don't even have toilets.
I told you, 'Seppina, that
you're going to live the life
of a proud American lady.
And I'm going to have my second
set of children with you.
And they'll be deluged
with the life that they could
never even imagine over there.
Like you were, Dick, as a kid.
These will be
your brothers and sisters.
-Please welcome to the show,
Ray Liotta.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ] Hey.
-How are you, man?
-Nice to see you, again.
How you doing?
-It's been awhile.
-It has been a long, long time.
Come on up.
-And we're supposed to fake
that there's people here?
-We -- no, no, no.
We're not going to --
we're just going to be honest
and say there's nobody here.
-I like it without.
-You do? Interesting.
-Yeah.
-What do -- what do you
like about it?
-I don't know.
Less pressure, less -- you know,
if you're saying something,
there's a joke.
There is no joke.
If they're not laugh--
I don't know. I don't know.
-I do -- it is a far more
natural conversation
without an audience.
-Totally. That -- yeah.
-Yeah.
That beats -- as we adjust.
-This is -- I want to --
I want to ask,
I'm so excited
about this movie.
I've heard great things.
Have you seen it yet?
-I have.
-You have.
And are you happy with it.
-I -- I -- I am.
It takes me a while, though,
when I --
to watch a movie that I'm in,
'cause I'm just looking at
so many different things.
-Are you very hard on yourself?
-I don't -- usually don't watch.
-You don't like to watch
yourself?
-Yeah, no.
There's certain movies --
this I really wanted to see.
There's other directors
that I worked with, that,
obviously I wanted to see.
But, in general, I -- I probably
only see less than half.
-Now, later on,
if you're in a movie
that you don't see and you
run into, say, the director,
do you admit to them that you
have not ever seen the movie?
-No. [ Laughs ]
Well, I would -- I -- see, we
would have gotten a good laugh.
-Yeah. Right there you go.
-That's when you need them
there.
-There you go.
We -- we'll -- we'll make it
sound good later.
-Put it in. I would probably
avoid seeing the director,
or just say, "Nah, I haven't
seen it yet. I'm not sure.
-Gotcha, gotcha.
This has been --
you have, kind of, been dancing
around "The Sopranos"
world for a while.
Like, a lot of -- I think,
part of it is people
always wanted to see you
in it, because, you know,
"Goodfellas" is this iconic,
you know, film
that's in the same world.
I think, maybe, 27 actors
in "Goodfellas"
then went on to be
in "The Sopranos."
-[ Laughs ]
-It's some crazy number.
And David Chase did approach you
about a part in
"The Sopranos," back
when the show was on TV.
-Yeah. I was -- I was in
Virginia doing "Hannibal,"
and he came -- we had --
he took a train out.
We -- we had lunch, and they
start telling me about the part.
And I said, "Nah, I'm not sure.
I don't know.
I'll let you know."
And for -- for --
who's the guy that got it?
-Joey Pants?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Joey Pants got it
and won an Emmy.
So, I made
the good move for him.
-[ Laugh ]
-And the right move for me.
-[ Laughs ]
And now, you find your way --
you find your way into the film.
What -- David Chase --
I love watching David Chase
do interviews.
I'm fascinated
to watch him talk.
Seems very serious.
Is he -- is he fun to work with?
-Huh.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if fun's the word.
But, you know you're
in really good hands.
-Yeah.
-If things are going South.
-Right.
He's just -- what I really liked
about him, he's just very
intense and knows what he wants,
knows what he likes and is not
afraid to say it.
-I'm assuming "The Sopranos" was
a show that you watched.
And, like everybody who was
involved in the show,
and now who's involved in the
movie, like, you know,
you want to be careful with
something that has -- you know,
so well respected
and so well loved.
Do you feel like everybody on
set knew they were --
they were, sort of, messing --
not messing with, but, like,
had to be delicate with
this beloved show?
-I never really watched it.
-You didn't watch
"The Sopranos?"
-Shh.
-Okay, go on.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
The few episodes
in the beginning.
But at that time, I just wasn't
into sitting home
and watching television.
-Yeah.
-You were out doing stuff.
So, I mean, I -- I saw episodes.
And, I said,
"Wow, this is really good."
Every now and then, you're
flicking and --
you know, there's an episode
that's on.
But no, I'm not -- I will.
I will, eventually.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Well, now, the good news is,
since this is a prequel,
you can watch it in order.
-Well, that's the other thing.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-It didn't matter.
And I didn't have to sound like
anybody, because --
-Yes.
-For some people, some of the
audience, some of the people
in our show go on to be on
the -- on the series.
-So, in the clip, we saw
Alessandro --
how do you say his last name?
-Nivola.
-Nivola. You know,
I heard there's a --
there's a fight in the film.
And, obviously,
when actors fight, you try very
careful --
you try to be very careful, not
to actually make contact.
-You'd think somebody would want
to be very careful.
-Yeah. But, I heard --
I heard Alessandro
clipped you a little bit.
-He did. He -- he did.
And I understand exactly where
he was coming from.
This is like
a nice shot for him.
And he wants to make it
as real as possible,
but he got a little sloppy.
[ Light laughter ]
-So he hits you.
And then, I heard you --
you didn't let him off the hook.
You made him --
you made him sweat it
a little bit.
-[ Laughs ]
So, he called --
found out how --
see how I was doing.
And I answer the phone, and I
said, "Not very good, Jimmy."
What-- what -- I said, "You
broke my jaw."
And he really thought that I --
I kept it going.
And, he, "Oh, my God, Ray, I'm
so sorry. I'm so sorry."
But, he didn't break it.
But it was good to make him
sweat a little.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
I think that's absolutely right.
Hey, so we -- we last worked
together --
I think this may be the time I
saw you, 2003.
-That's what -- yeah.
-2003, in this building,
you hosted "SNL."
And, I was actually texting with
my friend, Rachel Dratch, today.
Which is why
it's funny to see you,
because, this was, maybe,
for me,
the most memorable sketch you
did in the show.
This was a kids' show.
And over the course
of the summer,
Rachel Dratch
was a kid who became,
maybe, a little bit
more of a woman.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you were --
there was a lot of dancing
in the sketch.
-Yeah.
-You were -- you were a --
-A kid show.
-It was a kid show.
-You were the guy who
played the dinosaur,
and you were not --
you would not stand for it.
-Well, I -- I got the
cigarette in my mouth now
and a drink.
So -- we taking a break. I think
Jimmy was -- was the director.
And I'm upset. "Look at her."
I go, "How could you have her,
like, dancing like that?"
-[ Laughs ]
-Because when she danced,
things just --
-Yeah. Things happen.
-Go.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-And they went.
It was a really good --
-I thought it was a --
-Tina Fey wrote that.
Were you part of that?
-I was only -- only just to
watch and enjoy.
But, I thought it was an
excellent use of --
of Ray Liotta.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, congrats on the movie.
-Thank you.
-I'm so excited to see it.
There have been very few
movies I've been
anticipating this much.
And it's just
great to see you again.
-Oh, good.
I hope we don't disappoint you.
-[ Laughs ]
"The Many Saints of Newark"
is in theaters and on HBO MAX
on October 1st.